oggi saldati suo vice che non mi
dimentico sempre di ghirla s perché lo
chiamo folgaria
ma c'e la s mettiamola ragazzi l'ultima
vittoria che ho fatto la trovate appunto
nella live la prima video che ho fatto
riforme
ho vinto la corona ne open 3 adesso e
posso shop armi questa bellissima questo
bellissimo costume siamo già vestiti per
bene anche perché ho visto che le skin
cambiano ogni giorno quindi tu devi
avere sempre tre corone fronte che si sa
mai chi capita poco la skin incredibile
quindi l'obiettivo mio adesso è cercare
vince tre partite
ovviamente non in questo video di votare
che quando passano skin è fatta bene mi
prendo quella e leggevo avevo anche una
nuova partita sul po grace voglio vedere
se da ieri non ci gioco prima partita
partita fortunata secondo me one mic e
quanta gente ha sciacquato vista partita
male con the skin particolari schifo a
particolari ragazzi le trovate solo se
sciupate dlc ottima la partenza peccato
per il continuo però fa niente ok sono
primo ragazzi una bellissima tattica per
rivedere primi questa ve la dico quando
siete in discesa se saltate il vostro
personaggio prende la velocità di da
discesa slitta di più e va più veloce
quindi se siete in discesa assaltate
fidatevi
ci siamo ok varano di miei qualificati
con questa partita perché sono 30 della
sua volta non era cosa fanno sti due una
volta non erano trenta erano 34 35 va
beh niente male quanta gente ha
scioccato guarda questo caso tutte
sciacquate legato allo sciopero anche io
non ho mai fatto nella mia vita ma devo
farla o dava ai ragazzi in meta via
guardi noi ragazzi hanno capito come mai
non compaiono tutti i giocatori quando
c'è il tabellone ve lo spiego perché
molti quando perdono il sanno di perdere
left anno prima e il tabellone fa vedere
gli ultimi che non ho notato che cadono
però tutti quelli che le stanno in
partita non si vedono secondo me questo
ragazzi una cagata
perché è proprio bello vedere che cadono
tutti quindi il gioco dovrebbe tenerli
anche se so se hanno le stato almeno per
il livello secondo me ha senso primo
book live live questa per i try harder
ragazzi come dico mi dicevo anche in
live praticamente questa qua in chip
sempre perché guardate 28 qualificarli
quindi praticamente tutti non si
qualificano il discorso è che qua se
cadi
10 direttamente eliminato ragazzi occhio
perché qua molti fanno l'errore di tra
yard aree tipo io l'ho fatto in live
seca di tipo questo qua fuori sei morto
non risparmio rispondi più quindi se
eliminato la partita politico viene fa
la lenta questa majal cacchio di soste
palle occhio che questa è la parte
difficile però c'è sempre quello che si
ferma al traguardo che fa simpatico
complimenti zio proprio lui ne sapevano
rocket league speriamo 18 zig zelig
rocket linda mi incavolo ragazzi per due
motivi uno perché capito sempre nella
squadra con meno gente perché le match a
due squadre dispari
io non so per quale cacchio di motivo e
due perché dipende tutto dai miei
compagni squadra io sono forte al gioco
ma i miei compagni se fanno schifo non è
colpa mia posso farci niente e quindi ho
paura di perderla come la perde forte
bellissimo colpo di testa cristiano
ronaldo bravo ma spingo madonna che
rinvio chiellini occhio ragazzi adatta a
destra io lavoro questa di sinistra
tanto giocato rocket league sono brocca
visto che sono bravo con la mia placcato
guarda che sta rotolando dentro forza
forza anche due palle qua vigente spinge
devole puleri o se rimango indietro
perché se arrivano ad saperle ecco come
apparato questo spinge ragazzi ancora
nessun gol non è mai successo nella
storia vista partita nessun gol in un
minuto e mezzo
no che quell'opera oggi occhio o parate
siete scarsi come la morte era ovvio
mica favi come parte potente la grosso
macchina pirati era bravo va bene ti
ancora dio ricorso vari caso nessuno in
mezzo a tirare bravissima che paolo non
entra no va bene nei pozzi con capi ma
cosa cacchio cenni no ragazzi non posso
giocare quindi compagni chi era in
difesa qua chi è che ha un neurone tra
tutti noi ce l'avete voi perché uno in
difesa deve sempre stare colpa dei miei
compagni stupidine mai colpa mia
1 sempre in difesa se non stavo un in
difesa la palla la prendiamo dentro un
in difesa best game ragazzi siamo
ragazzi porte in faccia 321 letto qua
bisogna mandare sempre questo mi ha
fermato perché c'è la madre un po è che
l'ho vista l'altro ieri in autostrada
non ho la macchina ma l'ho vista allora
l'importante come per andare avanti gli
altri
tranquillo ti godi le porte già aperte
tener sbatti va benissimo e ha dato
l'addio di oddio sono primo primo
ragazzi
let's go il pavia ciao ciao a tutti 30
reining vediamo se riusciamo ad andare
avanti per bene la tattica ragazzi
finale il rollout e rimanere al lato
perché se tu rimani al lato switch tra
la penultima e l'ultima corsia così
esattamente e non cadi praticamente mai
perché sai proprio attento guidate si
eliminano da soli è molto semplice
switch tra questa è l'altra è molto
facile ragazzi sembra sembra difficile
suo livello ma per me è semplicissimo
non sono mai morto adesso loreto st
cagata sicuro muoio allora continuiamo a
cominciare gli altri sono quasi tutti
ammazzati perfetto poi va bè vinay ora
possiamo fare uno scontro a tim che
siamo bari adesso potremo fare rocket
league avrebbe senso invece no
quando siamo pari facciamo le cose
diverse allo ragazzi proviamoci tutti
uno allora qualcuno di pesto io
piuttosto sto io veramente se non siete
in grado di fare in difesa perché non è
possibile che siano sempre tutti in
attacco e in difesa non difende mai
nessuno ragazzi non ho capito se le
scrivo lungo la mia parte non ho capito
se le skin aumentano la probabilità di
colpire la palla perché ci sono alcuni
che hanno la skin più alta e quindi
magari la quadra colpiscono meglio ma
non ho mai capito in realtà se sta roba
funziona o meno
e poi ci sono io che ci passa attraverso
la palla ma quello è un altro discorso
io rimango qua e rimango qua che si
arriva la paro anche se ci faccio
attraverso non fa niente
bellissimo vigente spingete bravi paro
gol perfetto due palle dentro parodi ce
n'è una che tiro incredibile favi dai 8
secondi ci abbia fatto a 40 la god 50
perfetto marinai la sono giocata molto
bene
rimanete in difesa ragazzi fatti quando
quando c'è una partita del genere non
abbiate paura di rimanere in difesa
perché in ogni gol salvato e come un gol
fatto perché sennò venivano eliminati
sempre a qualcuno in difesa ragazzi
ricordatevelo mannaggia al capitano male
in difesa li ammazzerei 9 quali fai dai
te che questa buona ragazzi il hexagon è
difficilissimo ho visto delle tattiche
per provare
allora praticamente molti salta noce non
corrono saltano tra una piattaforma
all'altra per far sì che per guadagnar
tempo le tipo guardate qua si parte così
è veramente però quale alcuni saltano
prima su una piattaforma così pensato ma
sull'altra questa cosa che sto facendo
io questo mezzo per guadagnare quel
tempo possibile capito che non è male è
una bella tattica però il problema è che
poi la gente va di sotto e grado i buchi
abnormi nei quali ho poi caso in mezzo è
giustamente micron di calcio tantissimo
stato sono i corpi in alto
la partenza è buona la grecia sono
quello pinato in asso avuto però vedi
che adesso accadono in 26 piattaforme
perché dopo sotto si crea un varco
allucinante io invece devo puntare a non
avere questo varco però va bene sono
altri stanno cadendo ancora di sotto
quindi ottimo quindi ottimo quindi
ottimo by così buona partita del pari
questi ragazzi nostro meritando è la sua
realtà molto me ritardo però vedere se
scaturire un po di strada questo qua in
data me la sono tolta a me stesso
sospiri che anche gli altri
tale tecnica del salto ragazzo di
qualche mega utile oddio cosa ho fatto
bellissimo ho fatto una provata ragan 1
su auto elimina allora uno eliminato le
rimangono sette questa giocata raga e
bella pesante non è per niente facile
perché poi devi indovinare tutte le
strade che non sono state ancora colpite
non è facile sono colpi in alto e
ragazzo non è male non è male sta
giocata non è male basta giocata oddio
oddio oddio no madonna cadendo
tantissimo 7 su auto attenzione
proprio lui va dai 10 8 22 e vinto la
mia prima partita subito cioè non lo
fate una prima però porca vacca primo
video serio prima vittoria vedete che
queste tattiche funzionano saltare
sempre da un conto all'altro per
guadagnare tempo e fare attenzione sotto
che cosa c'è
ragazzi vi ricordo che for guys uscirà
sul mio canale tutti i lunedì e tutti i
giovedì quindi lo trovate come video
seguitelo perché farà un sacco di
successo sta già avendo un sacco di
successo
io punto a diventare uno dei top player
mondiali la partenza è molto buona esso
umile comunque resta umile quei ragazzi
meravigliosi è piaciuto iscriviti al
canale lasciato mi piace e condividete
video con tutti i vostri amici che
giocano a folger fai vedere queste nuove
tecniche che funzionano e noi come
sempre ci vediamo a un prossimo video
bella ragazzi
[Musica]